how do you guys decide to open with the
attack oh we had a draft where he
secured the power stone it just felt
like one and we thought all right why
don't we why don't we just start in the
middle of the scene that that's going to
knock the audience off-balance Anna's
already has the upper hand everyone's
had their ass kicked people are dead and
we just felt like it would be a more
shocking opening that would define him
as a character for the MOOC for the rest
of the movie and I'd say it's a grand
and transfer him as a character is that
you know he's he's already in the midst
of his plan and we're catching up to it
part another part of the reason why we
did that was the end of civil war the
idea that we've left the the Avengers in
a place where they're broken and
separated from one another and we knew
that created a vulnerability in them
because they were no longer together
they were no longer a team so the fact
that Thanos could strike fast and be one
step ahead of them was even more
threatening to them in the narrative
because again in order for them to
respond to this sort of thin O's in
order for the you know they would have
to sort of they had a long road to go
before they could get on the same team
again and which you know they never
actually do in this film
they never are United as a force in this
film and that was part of the concept of
having fan o's one step ahead of them is
that that was where they were most
vulnerable because they were divided